la función fx igual a 6x al cuadrado más
18 x más 12 entre x al cuadrado menos 4
no está definida en x igual a más menos
2 y podemos ver por qué es eso resulta
que si ponemos el valor x igual a más
menos 2 y sustituimos por x igual a más
menos 2 entonces
x al cuadrado menos 4 sería 0 más menos
2 al cuadrado en cualquiera de los dos
casos nos da 44 menos 40 y no tenemos
definido lo que significa dividir entre
0 así que esta función no está definida
en más menos 2 qué valor debe ser
asignado a efe de menos 2 para que fx
sea continua en este punto así que qué
valor le podemos dar a efe de menos 2
para que la función sea continua en
menos 2 pues antes que nada quiero
simplificar un poco la expresión de la
función
lo primero que noto es que puedo
factorizar un 6 el numerador y
escribirlo como 6 por x al cuadrado más
3 x
todo eso dividido entre x al cuadrado
menos 4 ahora bien esto es lo mismo que
6 x
y si me fijo en este polinomio de grado
2 en x al cuadrado más 3 x + 2 y lo
quiero factorizar lo que necesito son
dos números cuyo producto hacia dos y se
sumase a tres esos números son muy
fáciles de encontrar y son 2 y 1 así que
esto sería lo mismo que 6 por x + 2 x x
+ 1 si expanden si expande en este caso
verde llegarán a este polinomio de acá
ahora en el denominador tengo una
diferencia de cuadrados que puedo
factorizar como x + 2
x
x menos 2
ahora bien si x no es menos 2 entonces
puedo dividir entre x más 2 el numerador
y el denominador y en efecto cancelar
estos dos términos y decir que esto es
igual a 6 veces x + 1
/ x menos 2 y esto vale si x es distinto
de menos 2 de hecho tampoco vale si x es
igual a 2 positivos así que puedo decir
si x es igual a más menos 2 si aquí eso
es igual a 2 positivos entonces el
denominador de nuevo sería 0 lo cual no
es bueno así que esta nueva función esta
función
coincide con mi función original en
todos los puntos salvo en x igual a más
menos 2 pero esta función de aquí toma
exactamente los mismos valores que fx
cerca de más menos 2 en particular cerca
de menos 2 no importa podría ser menos
2.000 1 el valor de esta función
coincidiría con el valor de fx y eso me
permite afirmar que para que fx sea
continua en menos 2 tiene que tomar el
mismo valor que esta función en menos 2
esta función si está definida en menos
dos y esa función en menos dos vale seis
por menos dos más uno entre menos 2
- 2 lo único que hice fue sustituir x
igual a menos 2 aquí y esto cuánto es
pues sería menos dos más uno es menos
uno así que el numerador sería menos 6 y
el denominador sería menos dos menos 2
que sería menos 4
y esto me da tres medios así que para
que la función
efe de x sea continua en menos 2
efe de menos 2 debe valer tres medios o
dicho de otro modo
si defino una nueva función como
fx lo voy a definir en cachos
fx es igual a 6x al cuadrado más 18 x
más 12 / x al cuadrado menos 4 si x es
distinta de más menos 2
y fx va a valer tres medios
x es igual a menos 2 entonces fx sería
igual
sería igual a la función 6 por x 1
/ x2 y como esta función es continua en
el valor de x igual a menos 2 y ahí vale
3 medios
fx definida este modo también será
continua así que la respuesta al
problema es el valor que se le debe
asignar a efe de menos 2 es 3 medios